That's why you were brought here right right right right right.
Yeah because really writing about it was never on everybody like everybody pretty you know you remember that
and with Troy. I'm going to stay here and you will let me love that way for me like right before I went. Yeah yeah.
And then there was something about me I was really really cool across for a young guy like sixteen
and the Cross doesn't really know me.
There's a way to go with a friend like this description right on right now he's clearly got it right right.
No You know why can't they race right. You will not get one on one with you Jack.
You know life is not my right you feel if people can you actually can be said has actually formed you know that you
know that that was a group of about ten
or so people who knew what I was going to church all about why that was what I was up to do well here I started telling
people what life was like can you get here.
That was like ninety seven days to be the first strike me to be the first actual drug part of the way they run like a
holiday that you can go up to maybe hour to the bailout little meeting over there you know that really sort of public
meeting was was the only right one. The one that you would hire him.
Every ounce of gold and everybody know what we do have a way to look back and nothing's ever happened.
Live on a day when you're with your girl sitting up in bed
when I have respect for me that I can do this I really did it was a lot of the first hard drive got to be a life.
I mean I saw down the street a very first thought was oh I thought yeah well that's what they do.
That's why should we wish to get away with it. Try doing that in life will be a record for the right.
Can't treat yourself like that in the middle three that trying to block a young street arrangement that you.
This is the life. Are you going. This is the language you write that will be wrong. Yet you got it right.
It was a stick. OK while free trade. Thanks very much to you. That's right that's right.
YES YOU DO You are right I mean you were all right. You got it right and you're. I mean you guys.
Really you guys really Carol. It's your five year old boy I love you love you.
Everybody others really don't follow the leader like you do why give a shit what you think it's a good.
So you say you know you know. Well right there was a day we told you it was very much.
I don't think it was probably my college. There is actually some guy actually the other one.
But there are very really there is no McQuarrie you really do the country because everybody would want to talk to God I
mean if you believe it was all right. But it was a very gradually over the years.
If you try to get your funny bone right with my refund on the street clothes on.
Everything you could you can be like you know you know that you have really you know she was talking with you.
A very beautiful very carefully because competition.
The army just once they tried to take her down there was this thing.
That's what did you tell us that the price of one hundred dollars on the bridge was being raised by my full
and she doesn't very funny. Yet she made a movie in the States recently called pretty bright.
This was this was a working abroad she raises five.
They all up and you saw here was a case that she was just kind of in the room that was sitting right next to him
and she was a dedicated I love. What's on it now. Thank you very much going to a place on the menu here.
There was a guy who was very much. The guy was really really nice.
She was like you know your wife doesn't really go some of the things you want you want to do you really want to do you
can actually chicken little towns castle with your plate plate going down toward the rock why there's the Crown Street
on your right.
You go down there but for the road was a little just right there on the first corner
but it was the place where the right. Yeah gallery just all my thoughts exactly about the role.
It was a few little shops. Coffee County of the mine it's a Turkish coffee shop.
Previous to that was to go through my takeaway for thirty something for about three months the product was a very good
thing that it's about two years. Hear hear. Right but it's in the same block as the list that wasn't true.
It was and it was usually something like I mean once again it was when I came here.
I mean during the week possibly it was restored but you know I used to go on about yourself all your heroes.
You know like they're seeing some of the guidance at the time because if you look at this terrible angle of forty five
degree.
You can't use the very same day you brought up in the family that he would still like instructing things
and collectively warned about certain places and I knew you. Very well.
Where sky cool people will want me in the sun and things but I thought he was getting back
and he decided we should stop drinking.
It was the guy who sounded like launching into sort of like a Harley that was my river which I thought that was a big
name your particular Somebody had mentioned here.
I'm sure it was from the bridge once he'd gone back a couple weeks later I thought what I was seven my father loves me.
I mean they really did tell me where you're getting the Dewey.
But there was no problem with the sixty's was no problem about finding out where the casing was simply because they
needed a steamroller that people would talk about the you know all about where the parts of it was he didn't have to
say.
The last thing he has to do is that he got this
or he didn't say just what the place for this in the context of the sausage must go looking to get likes to see anybody
but I along with the early settlers of the early sixty's here because he knew that there was a sort of that I mean
you're talking about major gets to one but I don't really see it because at that time with the place.
It was actually just right there for a young player actually when you.
Yes I mean you know you know you guys hear what was yours because people like you
and you're writing a polite about the three The Real Story tonight with the role of the role of a really really really
really very mean if you like and you can tell. Well you know. You know with this.
Yes yes yes yes Miles get it could be not acceptable.
Again not easily create a place that is psychiatric and she actually was actually more than just sorry.
A child she held you know this oppression. You can pretty much get it I mean you need to when you're under a bond.
You know what they saw that I mean that I wasn't getting this is what my sixteen
and let go because that was a tepid existed. Let me have it and if you're a True. So ready to roll with me.
But they never do anything. Let me get yourself a conceptual get me to the city to get one.
They are going to take one of the state of the city from quite specific things I could never think to much Mike.
You develop and therefore when they do specify.
I mean for a long time they haven't necessarily the concept of what they're really like you really want to get there
yet again and this is a good place for you three.
Yes let's play because that's crazy like probably not really the way to get there is a problem with you anyway.
Thank you again this was just like somebody calling as far as right here but it's very slow coming in and
when the call yesterday was because he was just had a very you know just if you will
when they say oh we don't like this but if you bring up one.
We love to have a call because I mean so much of this is a lot of people don't like the going to be done immediately
once we've got the type of the type you would really shine if this stuff was recorded so someone somewhere might want
to do something on the stuff like a colleague of yours.
In all the different to different people that you believe there will be. This is.
I don't see many friends just promising that your life you know what you know that she will actually that was because
she was she like you might write a book very patient a little bit like that.
She was the one trying to push for it to you
and you actually you know what you did you hear Jack you know you enlightened the Myles Brand new baby. Very.
Really you just you're here very very because she said and you do you know Michael history will back up.
You just try to look just to give an example the last one very well the second the one with the right call.
I mean obviously none of the characters you guys have that you know me like I mean you don't get what you call a sex
life because obviously the guy thought it all about the money in the phone right.
All right well here in the remarkable number of really well somebody you know somebody is measuring what I think there
are chapters think some of the details are two chapters in that little really really backed up there are other things
like the way you have to come across.
Just the way you live your life and someone who has read a lot about you know all the strike literature
and my you know people in the twenty's and you know when you read this book and I say this one of the cross.
I mean our neighborhood before Mark was just really got to on this guy John Riley who died ten years ago was that all
right.
That's what the crux of something is always this book was actually it was probably the best source for scraps of welly
mine was killed. Thank you. Love life. Can you see it the Sydney Symphony Orchestra.
Yes I really aggressively was there and the funny thing is that playing music was.
Well it did really well for you what.